[Music]
for honor releases in less than a month
and if you plan to play it on PC you're
gonna need to know if your rig can run
it I met and you will need to meet our
minimum system requirements to watch
this gamespot news update Ubisoft has
announced for Honor's pc specs ahead of
the upcoming multiplayer beta weirdly
enough the minimum requirements are for
playing the game at low settings with
the resolution of 720p running at 30
frames per second that's not how most
people are going to want to play this
game but for that you'll need at least a
core i3 550 or phenom 2 x4 955 4
gigabytes of ram and a gtx 660 or HD
6970 the recommended requirements on the
other hand are replying the game with
high settings at a resolution of 1080p
running at around 60 frames per second
at the very least you'll need an i5 2500
k or FX 6350 in addition to 8 gigabytes
of ram and a gtx 680 or r9 280x this is
with vsync disabled so you should expect
to need higher-end hardware to take
advantage of advanced visual settings
for Honor's multiplayer beta runs for
four days beginning on january 26 while
the full game releases for ps4 xbox one
and pc on Valentine's Day for more news
about Ubisoft melee action romp and the
world of video games stay tuned to
gamespot
you